on peut rien faire pour arrêter de
vieillir comme Mick Jagger ou Kiss
Richard alors déjà peut-être que ça fait
longtemps que tu n'as pas vu Mick Jagger
et Kiss Richard est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment dire qu'ils ont arrêter de
vieillir je dirais non mais ils ont 80
ans voilà donc ils sont vieux c'est
comme ça et c'est déjà pas mal qu'il
soit arrivés jusque là vu qu'ils sont
collé toute leur vie mais pour répondre
à ta question est-ce qu'on peut arrêter
de vieillir bah non on peut rien faire
on peut vieillir très lentement si on a
le syndrome d'ylander mais je le
conseillerai pas après est-ce qu'on peut
bien vieillir oui il y a plein de trucs
qu'on peut faire pour mieux vieillir
genre manger équilibré avoir une
activité physique régulière regarder mes
vidéos mais en plus de tout ce que tu
peux faire pour vieillir le mieux
possible physiquement si tu veux deux
conseils voilà ce que je te dirais un
accepte que tu vieillis toute l'énergie
que tu vas dépenser pour faire croire
que non c'est de l'énergie perdue pour
faire des trucs cool et deuxième conseil
bah fais des trucs cool justement tu
peux rien faire pour pas vieillir tu
peux pas forcément éviter les maladies
les accident et cetera mais tant que tu
peux faire des trucs cool dans ta vie
bah fais les